today's episode of just getting started
is sponsored by geico
do you own or rent your home sure you do
and i bet it can be hard work
you know what's easy bundling policies
with geico geico makes it easy to bundle
your homeowners or renters insurance
along with your auto policy it's a good
thing too
because you already have so much to do
around your home go to geico.com get a
quote and see how much
you could save it's geico easy visit
geico.com today that's
geico.com hey everybody welcome to
episode three
of just getting started right here on
westwood one i'm your humble host rich
eisen we've already had some great chats
with
matthew mcconaughey the academy
award-winning actor and best-selling
author
uh also damon john the creator of fubu
and uh the shark from shark tank just
going through some origin stories going
through some stories of how some
people that we know and hopefully love
um
have gone about their business to get
their business to where they want
to be today and perhaps you can clean
something along the way of
maybe you just getting started on
something new or just getting started
with something that you wanted to do
that's the whole point of this show and
why it's called exactly that so let me
get right to it
my guest is somebody who has had a
couple
of reboots of her career that is now
going gangbusters with her owning her
own production business
after many years of being on cnn to say
the least
[Applause]
[Music]
and joining me here as promised is the
founder and ceo of soledad o'brien
productions
which she started uh almost 10 years ago
about
uh after leaving cnn and here on just
getting started
is the aforementioned soledad o'brien
how are you soledad hey i'm doing well
i'm you know all things considered if
you think about how crazy it's been
over the last year i feel very very
fortunate i've had
you know mostly healthy people in my
life in my game
school is kind of churning along and so
yeah net net
uh we've been we've been holding in
pretty well how old are your kids
kids they're not little which is amazing
because i have friends who got little
kids and it's so hard doing zoom school
with kids that you have to sit there
with but
my twin boys are 16. they just i took
them for their first drive with their
learners permits today
oh my god and teaching twins like that's
terrible
and and then my daughters are in college
i have a freshman in college so she's 19
and a
and a sophomore who's 20. well i've got
12 10 and seven
um so that's been um it's been something
it's been something you know they need
to get out a little bit more but um
it's it's uh you're right though we're
we're all
you know um healthy and you know
knocking on wood again
but that's the whole concept of this
show is that there are many people out
there
who are not um on the straight narrow
right now or
are thinking about restarting their
lives or rebooting their lives and again
you're a perfect guest
to have on a show like this one because
you've done it many times
you know a handful of times and so i
just want to get started
i guess with you is how how did you get
started in your career you started in
boston did i see that you're also
pre-med on top of it
yeah i started wbz tv uh as a
um as a pa and really as an intern and
then as a pa
and and and that sounds great but
actually it's because i
couldn't really handle a thought of
going to medical school i was an
undergrad at harvard
and i was taking a bunch of uh pre-med
classes with my sister who's now a
surgeon
so okay it worked out for one of us and
not for the other
and um and i remember she's she's a
researcher and a scientist
and she used to say to me why you know
you could you could take with you a
little card with all the formulas and
she'd say
why are you memorizing these things like
you should be able to deduce
y equals mx plus b right x y axis b is a
variable in space what else could it be
i'm breaking out in hives from my from
my science classes back data i
have not heard that equation in a very
long time so and it really wasn't that
equation but something like that and you
know
it was it was so interesting right
because she just understood and cared
about the science
and i was like oh i can memorize a lot
of stuff and regurgitate it on a test
and and it was interesting to see
someone who really i mean she was so
perplexed by me and i was
you were very different personalities
she'd love to sleep in late and rush to
class like like carrying a bagel and her
coffee and i'd like to get up early and
have my four-color pen but she really
wanted to understand the science and and
i actually was like well i think i'm not
really a scientist
like i want to i like the idea behind
medicine i like the people and helping
people generally but
i don't think this is for me and that
kind of set me into a bit of a tailspin
um so i left school and started and and
got a gig
working as an intern first and then
working as a production assistant at wbz
tv
so then how did you wind up in front of
the camera how did that happen bz
uh from bz i was working with a medical
reporter
and uh from there i started working at
nbc news and nbc news at the time was
really good about like
what do you want to do and how do you
want to get there and very helpful and
so
with their help i ended up going out to
san francisco which was like the number
five market at the time
uh and working at kron tv as a first
year on air reporter
your average reporter starting salary
was 90 000
they started me at 30. so
but i was so happy i mean i really and i
had so much to learn i mean i'd been a
producer by then at the network
and so i had pretty good skills but you
know it's a whole different
thing obviously to be on camera and to
and to be able to kind of think on live
television was a very different thing
and so it was really a wonderful
experience and i was really grateful um
but but it was a big
it was a big shift yeah i started my tv
career in just in northern california
just up the road from
san francisco and by me meaning uh just
up the road i mean
practically oregon in uh redding
california
and my my starting salary was 6.95 an
hour that's how much i was making
uh when i was it was it was uh but then
you know i i was there for about a year
year and a half and it was
it was a hell of an experience you know
i'm from new york city so if you ever
saw the tv show northern exposure
that was that was me you know like i was
the the
the new yorker in uh in in the forest
with the log lady
kind of but it was just an heck of a
different
experience for me and then i sent a tape
to a headhunter under the category of
why not yeah and um and espn found me
there how did how did see
did you go to cnn from there is that how
you didn't i was working
at cairo and tv which was an nbc
affiliate
and then uh from there i i actually had
a boss
who um who felt like there were enough
women on the air i wanted to learn how
to anchor
and my old boss at nbc a guy named bob
zell who did a lot of science reporting
for nbc for a long long time
and he used to say you know get as much
experience as you can
and i wanted to learn how to anchor and
and they said to me we have so many
women anchors like no we're done we
don't want any more
and and it was very clear that like
their concept of what i could do was
this which was sort of fine like but
i knew that i wanted to sort of stretch
into trying other things
and that's when msnbc was starting in
1996 and so i
jumped and um david borman who helped
start our show which was called the site
i used to when he would interview me
he'd say listen
everybody has a girl and a boy anchor
we're going to do something we're just
going to have you it's going to be all
you and i've never anchored before it's
just
we're 100 confident you you know and
then he tells this story at some event
about how
he would tell me that and then get on
the phone and say find me a guy to
partner
with this woman who doesn't know what
she's doing right right so i never
really knew that until many years later
uh but we
launched the site on msnbc which died
about a year and a half later when
princess diana
died because that's when cable news
shifted
into round-the-clock live breaking news
coverage and we had been doing a tech
show
you know taping a show uh and so our
cable show was
both very expensive and clunky right you
had to like tape it in advance and
deliver it
um and then suddenly you had breaking
news and they really started covering
you know breaking news every moment as
it was unfolding
so then i went back to nbc news because
i didn't really have a job anymore
uh i was still employed by them but i
didn't really have anything to do
and i kind of restarted over at nbc news
so uh a restarting uh a rebooting
at any point in this time as you're
making your way through
um how did you deal with the doubts that
you no doubt had
you know what's so challenging i i i
didn't i had a lot of confidence in
myself and i i was very clear about what
i
couldn't do when i couldn't do a live
shot i would sit down and really
plot and the good news in morning tv is
you know
we were the show before the today show
so we'd have a 5 a.m live shot at 5 30
live shot of uh 6 a.m lunch on the 6th
like if you couldn't get it by the end
of four tries
you know but every day i got to kind of
work on my
the same exact live shot over and over
and over again which was a tremendous
opportunity um you know i didn't have
doubts about myself but i
i did feel i did know that my bosses
didn't have tremendous confidence in me
and for some reason i knew that i didn't
want to be at a place where bosses
didn't have confidence in me
and listen i i mean i i i wasn't very
good
um but i was a hard worker and i felt
like i wanted to be in a place where
people valued hard workers and would say
listen you're a hard worker we got to
make you better but if you keep working
this hard we're going to help
too and we're going to build you in a
certain direction and that was certainly
the case when i got to nbc they were
like we're going to invest in i'm
i grew up in long island so i had a long
island accent and they're like yeah we
need to work on that
they sent me to juilliard to learn how
to stop saying coffee
and maul and call wow it comes right out
of you oh my god
call me later we'll talk about it oh my
gosh that sounds like something straight
out of saturday night live so that
that's impressive and when i go back to
long island i can
i can i pick it up so you're right back
in of course
scares my husband like who have i
married who are you
but i didn't have i i guess the one
thing i had a lot of clarity on
was one i'm a hard worker but also
i don't want to be around people who
don't believe in me
and that has kind of been my guiding
light in a way of
you know i was willing to work to figure
it out
it it's we're not operating on people
it's not brain surgery right we're
trying to figure out how to deliver a
show or
my husband was very helpful when i would
mess up live shots he would talk a lot
about
you know three sentences and he would do
a lot of like sports metaphors which
would
go over my head hey listen when you're
down in your head
you're about to punch you gotta like
what right three things just pick like
just you know just really pick three
things to focus on
and so my live shots became i'm standing
at the jail
behind me they're expecting to deliver
the announcement about the prisoner
you know he could be uh freed on
september 5th
and just kind of making it very simple
until i was able to figure it out
and i asked for a lot of help too i
think i was very open to
people helping me figure it out um but i
didn't
i had a good sense of what i couldn't do
but i knew it was it was learnable and
it was doable
i just didn't want to be around people
who didn't want to invest in me
well i mean and i i guess you were
fortunate to be able to
to have the people around you to help
you out and
i like the concept of keeping it simple
you know and
and and again that's part of the i i
guess
uh vagaries of what i'm attempting to do
with this podcast is
people might be sitting here saying well
sure it's simple to say you know you
don't want to be around
somebody who doesn't believe in you and
sure it's simple to try and keep it
simple but
sometimes you do need to have the
courage to say something
or to look within and believe in
yourself
you know i i'm did you at any point in
time however just think maybe i should
have gone
into medicine or or you just knew you
made the right move
i knew you were going about it medicine
would have been a very wrong move
so i never thought i should go into
medicine no
i felt like i can figure this out i just
need some time and i just need some help
listen it's live shots which are hard
but they're not impossible
and so i would ask people for help and
sometimes their advice wouldn't be very
helpful there was a reporter at nbc news
who said to me
finally which really stuck she said you
know it's like
being on the phone with your mom she's
not stupid and she's not nine years old
but she's not there so she can't see
so you need to describe it for her and
you need to explain it to her you need
to slow it down a little bit it's your
mom right she's not 100
read in on all this stuff it's really
like a phone call
but over the camera i mean literally
some people would say pretend you're
tall you're the camera is your husband
pretend
i'm like no i can't do that so no i
never felt like i should quit because i
liked it
i just felt like gosh i just can't
figure this thing out
and while i'm not a i do think
people have to sort of dig deep and
figure out what they're gonna do
for me it was much i'm a tactical person
so i had a list of three things that i
was working on
every day i had a list of like by next
week i want to be able to accomplish
this and i think that was my
my strategy to just have a running list
of like yep i figured this yes i figured
out this i used to say
um a lot um uh um
and i had to work on stopping that
and i put it on my list three things and
as soon as i solved one thing
cross off the list and add a new thing
to work on i do that to this day
and so often when i'm trying to explain
to people about you know transitions or
what they want to get to it's
for me very helpful to just keep lists
of like what are you trying to do what
are you trying to accomplish what are
you trying to solve for who do you want
to be around
what are you wearing like what in your
head is the thing you're trying to get
to and all those things will help you
figure out the career that you want to
go for
so um when you got to cnn
and um you know just i guess
fast forwarding through your your stay
there
because i know i get all the time why
did i leave espn
i get that all the time like today you
know some people will just hum the
sports center theme to me
in when i'm walking through an airport
you know obviously pre-pandemic
and i i haven't been there in 18 years
you know so i understand
you know how people might view me or
what have you and it really does matter
as to how i view myself
obviously but i get that all the time
now what i'm i'm wondering if uh
you know it's if it's up to you if you
want to compare notes
but i mean why did you why did you leave
i was at cnn for 10 years i really i
loved it i loved
i i traveled a lot it was very grueling
i covered a lot
every major disaster that happened over
the 10 years from 2003 to 2013 that i
was there
when i in 2013 i guess jeff zucker came
in as news president
and he made it very clear that he did
not see a future there for me in the
role that i had
he did not want me to anchor and he said
we would love to keep you on
we have a job for you it's not this one
of the terms of the job would be filling
in so i'd be anderson's villain or
somebody else's fill-in
and i guess two things happened one i
felt like i'm not sure i need to be
somebody's villain
and two i have four kids and there if by
then they were sort of in the middle
school
ages and i knew not having a a sort of
kind of regular schedule would be
really problematic like it wouldn't be
good for them it wouldn't be good for me
and i also felt like i had won a bunch
of awards and
was considered a good journalist and and
was working really hard that
i thought i could probably make a go of
of trying my own thing and and taking
the stories that i wanted to do and that
i was kind of known for
and and just figuring out how to make a
business around it of which i had really
no
concept of exactly how to do that um but
you know again it went back to this idea
and it happened to me a couple of times
over my career when you're talking to a
boss who really is like i just don't i s
you see a thing i don't i don't see that
thing and
it was very interesting to realize a
couple of bosses earlier that
you you don't need to be loved by
everybody to be successful
like it doesn't you know i i had been
very when i worked at wbz
everyone loved me and then i went over
here and went to nbc news and everyone
loved me you know and
at some point you know to i went off to
carowind in san francisco and they were
like
she's all right she's okay and to
realize like you can be successful you
can win awards you can learn a lot you
can have a great career
and everyone doesn't have to love you
was a very empowering
thing for me like i could go do a thing
and just figure it out
right i actually i actually appreciated
first of all i don't think i could work
at cnn today because i don't really like
the way that they do news but
but i did appreciate one thing he did
that other bosses
generally don't do he sort of told me up
front
and i have found historically people
sort of say oh my god we love you you're
amazing
we have such great plans for you you're
gonna start by filling in for anderson
but we have plans
and it's a lie and i actually
appreciated that he's like this is what
i see
this is it take it or leave it and so it
ended up saving me a lot of time because
i could say well i actually see
something else
and i could go hop and do that i was it
was a very rough year the first year
really a year and a half because i
didn't know how to run anything
i mean you don't i didn't have the
skills to run a business we have 13
full-time employees now
and five shows in production and i do
anchor a couple of things and report on
some stuff as well so you know just
figuring out like the structure and
how to do a business plan like all this
stuff wish i'd studied a little bit of
that when i was in college
but i never i never regretted the jump
because it's sort of like
having a boyfriend who's like i don't
love you you know you should leave when
someone tells you we don't love you you
really
need to say thank you for telling me
i need to go you know it's funny when
i i left espn part of the and you're
just saying about
that you don't like the way that cnn
covers news
right now and the way that cnn was
beginning to cover news
affected in a way the way that
sportscenter was covering
sports and for
two one two reasons one is not the
specific to what cnn was doing
but it was a combination of
people were beginning to see the sports
highlights on their phone
so my bosses assumed people who tuned in
to
the show i was hosting already knew the
results
which was new i started in 96 and by the
early arts
they not only assumed that people would
know but because i i think cnn was the
ad
was the uh creator of the the bottom
line
constant scroll right the crawl at the
bottom i think that was based out of 9
11
to continue putting the news to the
bottom am i right about that
it started even earlier it was the
number one thing americans complained
about in cnn the crawl
the crawl and so i was though i i
soledad i was the only sports center
anchor who went into management to
complain about the
crawl at espn because
i was trying to set up a highlight or
story that
i assumed people didn't know and the
final score was being scrolled right
across my chest
so i was beginning to chafe about that a
little bit but
the thing that really affected me was
crossfire
i swear the crossfire concept of
instead of me being the anchor to
tell in an entertaining or informative
way what
was happening i was now the anchor
between
two analysts who are going to come on
and argue about why something happened
and their viewpoints were always
figuratively black and white there was
no
nuance there was no nothing and it was a
lot of barking in my ear and i'm like i
i don't want to host this show anymore
and then when my contract came up it was
um an executive at the time named mark
shapiro who basically looked
at me and said you're a sports center
anchor and i'm like i
kind of think i'm something else and i'd
like to try something else
and nothing really came to it thus
i'm not with espn for 18 years now but
you know what's interesting it's that
piece of like i
think i'm something else i mean i think
that's what so many people feel this
idea of like
i think i'm more than this little thing
that you're giving me and
but you gotta follow it you have to five
percent 100
i mean the thing that i found the most
joy in my first year which was really
stressful
because you know when you start a new
job and you're kind of like i can't
remember where the bathroom is and i
gotta ask that guy over there
like that awful feeling of i just can't
i can't figure it i remember when
someone came to me and said
something about my quarterly taxes i was
like there are quarterly taxes
and they're due now we can laugh about
that now but that was pretty stressful
um you know so every day was a i just
would like to get through the day
not learning something i would just like
to be like yeah i had a normal day
but the thing that was so interesting i
was sitting in a meeting one day
and pitching an idea and how we would
structure the deal
and everyone's like that's a really good
idea we like the way you're structuring
that
and i was like holy [ __ ] i'm a person
who structures deals
right i know how to do this it's a
completely different thing than i had
ever done but i knew i really
understood how to do it and and it's a
really great feeling to say there is
this other part of me
of what i like to do and i'm and i'm
good at it um that that's been
really really kind of saved me for the
first year and a half because the first
year and a half was pretty rocky we were
always
profitable which was lucky a lot of my
deals
um like leaving my exit deal from cnn
right required them to take on a lot of
production
from me so it made us profitable
immediately
which a lot of people don't have so that
was very lucky but you know you still
had the arc of figuring out and making
mistakes
making so many mistakes no yeah i guess
you are lucky in that i
i got a box to put my belongings in
and see you later you know and um and
that was the end of
you know they leaked my uh my departure
as uh
not renewed you know it was it was tough
for me
it was tough for me because it was my
only identity it was my dream job it was
my
only identity to that point in time um i
did meet my uh
well it was but i did have another place
to go
you know it just was a while to get
there um
and i used to you know at cnn when they
would when they would
um fire you off of a show they i left in
the middle of my contract so they had to
pay me
out um but but when i was
laid off of the show you they tell the
new york times first
right so you read it you kind of sense
that something's happening but you read
it in the new york times
yeah yeah in the morning before you
anchor the show
and then you have to kind of spit out
that you know do a a goodbye
and you have to kind of set up this
whole thing and usually you have to
anchor for two more weeks
when everybody who's watching knows you
know you've been fired
this person over here is now taking your
job i mean it's so
it was so embarrassing but now i feel
like
you know if you can make it through that
and treat the people around you well
you know like i loved our our staff was
great our team was great
you know the floor guys were great like
you know my goal was always like we're
going to do our
we're going to do a good show and and
make ourselves proud
as we walk out the door like i think you
know i felt like if i could get through
that then i could pretty much get
through any
humiliating things yeah because your
your identity
is clearly obviously you know the
business that both of us
are in you know our identity is a brand
you know our identity is also what
what you know people who want to
hopefully turn
on uh a device you have to say it this
way now it's not just tv
and and and stick with us you know and
stick with us
and and want to hang with us that that
means something
but deep down though it really is who
you are
as a person and even though
you know you need to move on onto
something
and you may have something to go on it's
still an out-of-body experience
that you have to really find the reserve
within you
to just say screw it you know i believe
in what i'm going to do
things may be tough right now i don't
know how i'm going to ever
maybe reach the same success that i've
just had
but i'm going to try and um
you know certainly if you're moving to
another job where you're competing with
the place you just left
it it adds a little extra oomph you know
but
uh for me it really was um it was
jarring
and it took me a long time to get to get
through it and get over it
you know yeah to this day it's really
hard and you're right
to this day i have people who'll say oh
my god i
love you on cnn and i like today right
like they saw you today right
i got to the point flight attendants who
apparently don't watch a lot of tv
right i finally got to the point be like
oh my gosh thank you so much
why why bother explaining and you know
and it comes from such a good place
right like what
what a great person to oh sure i know
here's my here's my my story on that and
then we'll take a quick break and then
come back and talk about your here and
now right now
soledad so again one of the best parts
about my
um job is and i think i kind of picked
up did you meet your husband through
work is that how you met your nose oh
okay um in college we met in college
okay because so he was working because
you mentioned he was working you through
your live shots
i just forced him to help me with my
okay sounds good okay very good
well i met my wife in the newsroom at
espn when she when she started working
there about a year after i was and then
she went to leave to los angeles to be
on the air
and then she was going to move back east
because we're getting married and that's
when espn told me to bounce and then we
were back to
uh to uh though to the left coast but
long story short the reason why i'm
telling you this is she was locked in
with the lakers in the nba
in the first year that i moved out here
to be on nfl network
which was in 11 million households
compared to the 110 million i was on in
espn
so we were on basically directv in small
little cable outfits
when we first started and it was the nba
all-star game
in staples so my wife had us all locked
up
due to her connections and we were we
were we were we were right in everything
so i'm standing there at staples and it
was like early 0-4
um right i guess that's what it would be
right around the all-star break of the
200304 nba season
some guy comes up to me and he goes dude
i love watching you every morning
right now and i but so i'm my first
thought was like
so do you have nfl network because i
just wanted to meet somebody who
actually
had what i was on right so the guy says
to me what are you talking about
and i'm like um do you have nfl network
i'm on nfl network now and he goes
you're not on espn anymore
like and this was damn near half a year
later
and i'm like no i'm not and i swear he
goes like this he goes wow
are you all right like he asked me if i
was
okay and i'm like i can fog up a mirror
if you want you know like i'm still the
same guy i'm
i'm happy i'm living out here now but it
really was one of those things where
i i'm like [ __ ] you know i understand
it though like listen when i left nbc to
go to cnn
the number of people who said to me it's
the bet the today show
is the greatest platform in the world
why would you ever leave
and i was like well technically i anchor
weekend today and like it's
it's a great thing but i want to go do
more
i was actually surprised it surprised me
that i mean and good friends like close
personal friends could not imagine that
you would choose to go do something that
was harder and more challenging
and in a way you know cnn was so much
less known and kind of this
random our morning show was um and we
hadn't had this sort of
2005 was a year of just
back-to-back-to-back-to-back-to-back
breaking news and i think that was
really helpful for cnn in terms of kind
of its place in the
world but you know again i think the key
to me has always been like you got to go
do the thing you want to do
and everyone's going to weigh in and
once you can just get past that and come
up with whatever your answer is right
they
i mean again i just found it easier
instead of telling people that i wasn't
there because they had
said that they watched me every day i
felt embarrassing them
if i said literally i'd been gone for
eight years i just finally was like oh
thank you thank you i know because
you're still the same person and again
that's part of you know uh for anybody
who's out there taking in this pod
obviously we're talking about our
businesses but i think it still is very
um germane i think you can absolutely
sit here and think if you want to try
something else and if you
believe in yourself and you think what
you're doing right now
isn't the right way or the right path
and you're willing to take the risk
you know again soledad you know it's
it's good that cnn gave you
you know um some some business when you
when you left to start your lawyers made
them yes
there you go uh it if you if you had
that
you know great you used what you had to
your advantage but still
i mean again and that's one of the
things i want to hit here
uh in the here and now in just a second
you know i just started
my own business with my show and i'm
i'm just learning on the fly you know
what i mean and i can only imagine your
head must have been spinning
but it's so much fun it's exhausting and
terrifying but like i really
enjoy it i remember my first year i had
people
i work with a guy and he was so mean to
me my very first project
and i just remember having this sense of
clarity like if you're going to work on
your own and you're going to work all
the time and it's going to be so hard
at least you shouldn't be around people
who are terrible right like at least i
get to pick
yes the rule and the rule is if you're a
jerk i don't want to work with you
and that was you know like it became
like a little guiding light like okay so
our company is going to have
this no jerks get to work here and and
that was a really good start of
you know i don't like feeling when you
work in a big place sometimes you have
to work with people you really dislike
and who whose values you think are bad
and don't reflect you
and to be able to say i'm gonna be
responsible for
the tone of this company like my job is
to make sure that the environment
is good for what we're trying to do like
that's kind of
fun that's amazing that's you know i had
no idea how to do it but it was a kind
of amazing concept
how do you choose what you what you work
on how do you choose what you want your
production company to
focus on especially your your current
project that i'll give you the floor on
yeah we i think we think about what
we're known for we do a lot of reporting
on race
and access and inequality kind of a lot
of the projects and documentaries that
i've done over the year
sometimes people come to us and say we
want you to do a documentary or we have
funding to do a project is it
interesting and
i really have a wide range of things
that i'm i'm very interested in so
rarely is it like ugh no interest at all
and um
and then we we for things that are not
funded you know if we have a great idea
we start marketing it and then pretty
quickly you can see is it is it going to
go or not and if it's not going to go
even things that we love
if you can't sell them and it's not just
going to be a labor of love then you you
actually have to move it to the back of
the line and decide
you know what can you sell what can you
bring to a network what does a network
want to buy
how could you create this this project
so that's how you're you're deciding how
do you think your
again uh your your current project is
going right now
solid the project we're doing for bet is
called disrupt and dismantle it's been
really
interesting and it was weird shooting it
during covet 19 because i
had a lot of trepidation about getting
on planes and staying in hotels i mean
the middle of the pandemic uh i really
enjoyed the the concept which was
looking at structural racism
which nobody ever wants to talk about
that literally makes people roll their
eyes back in their head
and actually trying to connect the
history
what exactly happened here in this you
know state of texas
that brings us to today and this woman
who has a hundred thousand
tons of shingles dumped in her backyard
like how does that happen
it's not just happenstance that there's
a whole system in rules and red lying
that happened not just in the state of
texas but around the country
that led us where we are today and then
being able to also
say you know what we need to do we need
to uh
think about solutions as well so i love
the concept of being able to do both of
those things
well and and and i also see how you um
how you handle your business on uh
twitter um love twitter too bad twitter
doesn't pay any money i think i'd be
like
if i could just have a gig on twitter
yes
so amazing how how uh often does your
finger hover over the send button
almost
does it go to the cancel button at all
not very often
i do try to be more sassy than mean
and i think that uh you know so so
i would say not not super often you know
i i don't regret things that i send i've
tried to be
i try to have a strategy around it
that's factual and not just like
this person's jerk but sometimes this
person's a jerk is a
factual tweet right and um
so when it when it comes to the state of
you know twitter today um i i always
wonder
sometimes what is real and what's not
and by that i mean just because i'm
seeing it in the palm of my hand it's
right in front of me right
you know you're you're seeing the
awfulness sometimes of the world you're
all
right in real time right in the front of
your hands i mean and that's the way
i've seen so much of the awfulness of
2019 and 2020 and obviously the first
couple of weeks of
of 2021 um and
just because somebody with three
followers can fire away at me and tell
me that i
suck you know or or put some sort of
absurd
counter-argument that does not require a
response
doesn't mean that that's the prevailing
thought
that's out there in the world i think
you really
have to have a certain temperament for
twitter and you know what often some
days i'm like i'm gonna go to instagram
and look at pretty pictures of voices
because that's what i need to do today
but but
but for twitter first of all you have to
realize that people are trying to guide
you into a conversation right the only
way that they think about growing their
following
is if in fact they're able to um to
connect to you
right so that's what they want to do
it's not real and also if there's ever
any outrage or someone responds to you
in a way
because they've misinterpreted or you
wrote something but you didn't mean it
that way whatever right
if you literally stop for 36 hours it
just rolls into the next outrage you
just miss it
there are days when i'm so busy that i
haven't checked in on twitter for a day
or two
and everyone's talking like i guess dr
seuss did something i don't know i kind
of missed it
it's not back it's gone i it was 36
hours it's gone away
no i believe it or not sold it out it's
gone beyond 36 hours
uh you know as a matter of fact when
when when this pod uh
finally hits it it might still be going
on but you know
there is something that you're
constantly on
with twitter by on i mean you know on
top of
is members of our profession putting in
240 characters
something that is a shorthand version
of a story that requires far more nuance
and you believe and think
that this is what the person actually
means and they might
but um anyone who reads it without the
context will think
something entirely different from the
truth
i just don't understand it it actually
really
it was happening for a long time but
really i think under president trump it
happened a lot right so it'd be like
president trump says the moon is made of
cheese and that would be a headline
you're like
right but but we all know the moon's not
made of cheese why would you
add erroneously add lies add
experts disagree i mean and this idea
and i think it was
first i thought it was just a mistake
and then it became pretty clear that
people were doing it so often that it
it was a way to kind of get click bait
you know reporters
didn't really want the context and the
explanation and
he said this but this you got to
understand that it was really just about
getting
clicks and it was so sad and depressing
for me it really i think the state of
the media
i love being a journalist but boy it has
just been so
disappointing because people need to do
better
um it's just so sad and there's a
million reasons why and so i i have
tried to call it out because sometimes i
think
well you know right when you're in the
middle of a thing you can explain to
people how the system works
because they don't really understand it
you can say let me let me explain to you
how this came
to be here because there's a whole
system behind it it didn't just pop up
on the air
and so i've tried to do that and explain
to people but it just
i've been so surprised at how
bad journalists have been on things
where they should be going for clarity
now obviously everyone's going to tweet
pictures of their
dog and their kid and their halloween
costume and the cocktail they're
drinking all fine but
if it's an area that you cover as a
reporter right
like this is where you're actually kind
of bringing your reporting
to twitter i think it's appalling and it
happens
all the time so it's been very um it's
that part has really bummed me out about
well it seems
it seems that um anchors on tv
um need to be real-time fact checkers
24 7 365 that they need to have the
facts at their fingertips
and the number of times that somebody a
politician
would come on and prevaricate um
over and over again it's kind of like
the version of twitter where
if you continue with one thing after
another after another
after a while the first thing that would
normally provoke something
so monstrous it could actually lead to
somebody being
uh jailed in trouble charged or
losing their uh their seat
that's gone because we're already on to
the next thing and so
what would you do like if i could put
you in situation
of soledad o'brien productions is now in
charge of say your former
place of business or any other news
organization what would you do
what would be the first rules of
engagement for you to
tell your charges what to do
i think if you put people on tv who you
know are lying
you are failing so number one you can
make a mistake in good faith
and you could even slide a little bit as
a politician i think that's what they
like to do and talk about kind of their
goals and dreams and hopes for the
future but if you have someone on who
literally lies you should you should
just never put them on again that's my
rule if you lie to me intentionally
you're just never on my air again
absolutely not number one number two
stories that have nuance can be covered
like stories that have nuanced the issue
isn't the fact checking of the anchors
the issue is
maybe this one shouldn't be debated by
two former congress members
maybe this one should be a reporter
going in the field and explaining
this really complicated situation for us
costs a little bit more
might take him a couple of days to shoot
it and edit it and bring it back
but like wouldn't we want to educate
people as opposed to having two people
who are
some of them making stuff up on the air
and i think
that that's the thing i find frustrating
the version of people yelling at each
other is very dramatic
right highly dramatic but it doesn't
educate people
it doesn't inform them and often it just
spews misinformation
so if it's something complicated don't
go to them if you want people's opinion
on something sure that might be
interesting there's a place for that
but often you just need reporting
sometimes the
the talking heads contradict the
reporting
of the people they pay to report i mean
that's insane right so it's a game it's
not really
about informing the public i would not
carry anything live that is spewing
misinformation
and listen if you have a president who
lies a lot i'd say he's the president we
absolutely have to carry
uh his press conference we're going to
run it
you know chop it into pieces and bring
it to everybody the president had a
press conference
here's the 15 things he said and we're
going to that we're accurate and honest
and here they are
you know you can there's a million
things to do and this idea that
everybody's hamstrung
into taking everything live and putting
on people you know on the air who don't
deserve to be on the air
is insane it's just not i mean you can
educate people i do a show called matter
of fact it airs on hearst
because we're pre-taped we often don't
get congress members understandably
because we pre-tape you know sometimes a
couple of days before
the show airs and and we can't go back
to them and get a fix on it so i
often sort of don't go to them there's a
zillion other
experts than congress people and
senators
right you could actually understand the
story from someone
who's in the middle of it and who often
isn't a partisan right they can just
explain the issue to you so at least
people walk away
understanding it there are so many
alternatives
i think it's crazy when an anchorman
interviews his brother
who's the governor i would never allow
that in a million years
i don't in a pandemic around a serious
issue
it's not funny i i you know that kind of
stuff to me that would end
in a moment just no one's bringing me
into don't bring me in to run it though
but it's so easy like it's not it's not
complicated right it's just saying
we're going to hold a standard to making
sure it's accurate
it's informative people walk away with
accurate information and when there's a
debate it's going to be smart people
debating something so
people learn from the debate they walk
away and say wow that is really
interesting
i heard from a really smart person here
and a really smart person here
not two congress members who jump in on
any topic that's ridiculous
but it's cheap inexpensive
or cheap which one do you want to use my
mother would say inexpensive
inexpension oh man
i do want to ask you about real sports a
little bit um such a great so
i mean that is you know my wife was a
producer for real sports for several
years and
um just we we watch it and um
it is truly remarkable it's very very
well done and it's
it's um it's a gold standard there's no
it's a show that knows what it is you
know i gotta tell you one of the things
about real sports is that
you you know there's no sort of they
they understand their dna
there's not like oh we're shifting and
we're gonna now do this and we're now
gonna do this and we're now gonna do
this i just love that like
you know what a real sports story is and
you know what is not a real sports story
i love that is there a way that you
check brian's notes on his yellow legal
pad is he scrolling
people only ask that they're always like
so what's brian writing
uh he does a lot of scribbling and i
think he thinks about like little words
it's not really like sentences um but
he's you know i
i used to years ago get coffee for brian
gumbel
at the today show look at you and so
when i
started working at real sports someone
said to me so you used to work with
brian at the today show now you work
with brian i'm like uh i used to get
coffee for brian at the today's show
it's kind of different he worked he was
the first
play-by-play voice of uh football on the
nfl network
because you know the nfl network when we
first started covering games
um the question was well how is the nfl
going to have a booth um
that you can trust to say this coaching
decision was not good
or that call by the officiating was
terrible if it's owned and operated by
the nfl
and my boss steve bornstein who's smart
enough to have hired me twice at both
espn nfl
nfl network reached out to bryant to see
what he want to call games
because nobody was going to sit there
and think that brian gumbel was saying
something just because the nfl wanted
him
to say it and he did it and i got to
work with him for a couple of falls and
it was awesome
it was awesome just being around him
right i bet so okay soledad uh i before
i let you go is there
one thing that you can tell everybody um
just your one tenet that of success
or belief in yourself from your origin
story or not to just leave everybody
with
soledad there is this mythology that the
job you're leaving
is the only job the only platform the
only place you're going to be successful
it is so ridiculous
it's just not true when i left nbc it
was like
nobody leaves nbc and i went to cnn and
ended up having a great
career it really built my reputation
when i left cnn to start my own thing
where i really didn't exactly know what
i was doing it was like
nobody really leaves this way and you
can
you can for me it's always in the list
making
just it keeps me on track what do i want
to get to where do i want to be
what am i worried about what am i doing
well what needs to change
what are the goals for next week what
are the goals for next month but
this idea that there's only three jobs
is just
complete [ __ ] and i just really want
people to understand if they do the
research
and if they really kind of make sure
they're figuring out how to make that
leap
intelligently they can do it and be
wildly successful they really can it's
not brain surgery soledad thanks for the
time
really appreciate it and let's uh let's
keep chatting down the road
i follow you on twitter i'll i'll just
keep uh
keep an eye out for for more of your
pearls of wisdom that i really enjoy
thanks thanks for having me
you got it that's soledad o'brien right
here on just getting started
well that was a lot of fun right there
with soledad o'brien and
look you know one of the things that she
she talked about because
i do like to close the show with
something that happened to me
that i either didn't feel like
interrupting
uh the flow of the conversation with my
guest but something that a guest says
that
leaps out to me was her
realizing that um what she was
doing was not something that she wanted
to do
and she needed to do something about it
which is
you know in her case
going from pre-med to tv i can't imagine
honestly
i mean i went from uh reporting
at a local newspaper to grad school to
small market tv and then i
i kind of hit the lottery ticket by
going to espn
but i knew early on when i was at my
hometown newspaper the staten island
advance or as the locals would say
advance because yeah i've got that new
york accent whenever i can
dig into it too you know what i'm saying
um because that's where i'm from staten
island new york but
it was an incredible experience i worked
with some great people some great
reporters there
but i didn't want to be a news reporter
i just didn't want to be one
and i remember you know i think i told
in a previous podcast
uh my epiphany behind the wheel covering
uh the police beat at es at uh i knew
i'd say espn but it's uh
the staten island advance and not
wanting to
chase ambulances i mean i was doing
exactly that and that's when i
i applied to go to grad school but i was
beginning to get my first sense of you
know what i am just not
cut out for hardcore journalism i'm just
not
i'm not cut out for the hard news and
it there was one moment it was a
terrible moment
at at um in in um
in my home borough in staten island if
everyone recalls
george bush senior poppy bush bush 41
had
a a program called the thousand points
of light
where they would honor an american in
every day american
for doing something at their job or in
their community
they were a point of light that somebody
should do something for others
that somebody was a pillar of the
community they were one of the
thousand points of light for george bush
senior
and there was a a high score a school
principal
from staten island who was a principal
in the red hook section of brooklyn a
pretty tough section of brooklyn
who would frequently go to the homes of
kids who were truants who didn't show up
and go and go get them in their house
knock on the door and say come on let's
go to school
and he turned to be out to be one of
bush seniors thousand points of light
and sadly one day he went to go get a
truant
to say come on let's go to school and
he was caught in some gunfire and was
killed
and i remember
the editor of my newspaper
was looking for the lead reporter i was
not the lead reporter i was again fresh
out of college about a year or two and
the lead reporter she was out on another
assignment now this is the early 90s
so there's no cell phones there's no
nothing that that the lead reporter was
one of the only few
members of my newspaper who had this
huge
walkie-talkie system that had only the
range of about two three miles outside
of the newspaper
and um she wasn't there and
he looked at me goes you you know rich
or richard
that was my byline richard eisen future
shows i'll tell the story about how i
chose to be rich eisen for a
sportscaster but
at any rate he says to me go um
go to the house of the principal and ask
the family for comment
and i was just stunned
like what like go to the house of
the guy who just got gunned down they
just lost their father they just lost
their husband they just lost their
you know point of light
and i should go to their house a
stranger a perfect stranger albeit from
the staten island advance
but i should be the one to go ask for
comment
i remember i went to the back closet
area where the supplies were and i
grabbed a
notepad and i might have sharpened the
same pencil about 15 times just trying
to kill time i was
i had a pit in my stomach i was just
freaking out i didn't want to do this
like i i i just felt that would be so
intrusive
and um sure enough i'm getting set to go
and the lead reporter
thank god she came right back in the
office and was told about it and
did a heel turn and she went and she did
the job
and i thought to myself not anything ill
of her
because this is what the job entails
you're us a
news reporter you're reporting on the
news that this thousand points of light
per
principle had been
killed and in a tr it's a tragedy
and you know you're covering it and that
is
i guess to find out from the family some
sort
of statement about him to honor him i
guess
i i don't know but it was her job to do
it and it was my job to do it and i just
didn't have it in me
and i remember sitting there i just
can't do this and so i'm like well what
am i going to do i can't break into the
sports department there was literally
a 40-year veteran there a 30-year
veteran there a 20-year veteran there i
mean there was a small handful of guys
in the sports department i
i so i continued to do the job but i
knew i wasn't cut out for it and i felt
that in the pit of my stomach and then
one day i just said i got to do
something else
and it it was very nerve-wracking to
come to that decision
but thank god i finally made that
decision and i stuck to it
and i kept going i kept going until i
got what i wanted
and um it was a lot of hard work and a
lot of doors slammed that you'll
probably hear those stories about in
future episodes of this pod but
just wanted to share that want to thank
everybody for taking in this episode of
uh just getting started please subscribe
if this is your first time listening to
it go back and listen to the library of
the previous shows
and give us that five-star rating
because that's the good stuff we'll see
you on the next episode of just getting
started
you